you
hello everyone and
complete workflow so
to protein it is presented by Michael
Liz PhD a senior manager in R&D and
thermo Fisher Scientific I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by Lab roots
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about our sponsor
is it WWE thermo Fisher com before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem please join me in
welcoming dr. Lynn I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you for
the kind introduction and hello
everybody for this little webinar about
our complete workflow solutions from
gene to protein so my name is Michael
Liz I'm with gene arts in 16 years here
in Germany and I want to tell you a
little bit about our service which we
eventually have expanded and going
beyond a simple gene optimization and
gene synthesis to actually use these
genes to express and purify proteins in
mammalian systems for our customers
so a slight overview of the agenda I
will introduce you and give you a small
overview about what gene synthesis
actually is and what then next what gene
optimization is so the design the in
silico design of sequences prior to
their actual synthesis then I want to
give you an overview of the results of
anime lien multi gene expression study
which we did with optimized genes and
tell you a little bit about the
mechanisms of gene optimization how does
that actually work within the cell and I
give you an overview of the applications
and the benefits of optimized genes for
expression talk a little bit about a
protein expression systems at thermo
Fisher and then of course go deeply into
the gene to protein services that we
offer and then open for your questions
and hopefully my answers so what are
synthetic genes I think by now its
really a commodity it wasn't that way
when we started with gene art some 16
years ago
synthetic genes are double-stranded DNA
of course and they can have any length
they we routinely synthesize over 10 KB
genes in length and they actually can
have genome size so they are several
hundred kilobases in size the design of
synthetic genes is completely free so de
novo synthesized genes can be made upon
any specifications that the scientist
may require and of course certainly all
genes that we produce our 100% sequence
verified
now how does gene synthesis work it all
starts in silico so imagine you had take
gene from jellyfish GFP and you want to
transfer it to the fruit fly and of
course this works because the synthetic
the the genetic code is universal and
all we all speak the same language
however I would say that the dialect is
a little bit different and what I mean
with dialect this that the synonymous
codon usage in different organisms is
different and this is where we can do an
adoption in the computer and modify in
these cases here the wubble basis marked
in red to match the most frequently used
codons in the fruit fly so this is all
in silico now we have an electronic
sequence in the computer and the next
task is of course to turn this into a
tangible molecule that starts with oligo
synthesis we have apparently Europe's
largest oligo synthesis lab here in
Regensburg in germany but to date we
entirely use it for gene synthesis so
here of course we have the four anodite
say c g and t and on the machines they
are made into all egos which have
lengths something between 50 or 100
nucleotides
are designed in a way that they overlap
each other like you will see on the next
picture here the animation starts story
apparently it does not start with the
animation but anyway so they are
designed in a way that the ollie goes
they overlap each other to eventually
assemble a full length molecule that
molecule then is not covalently linked
but these missing gaps of the
oligonucleotides are filled in with
polymer races and after a few cycles of
cycling basically this primer extension
reaction leads to full-length molecules
which can then be amplified sorry now
you will see the animation so the ollie
goes they find each other the gaps are
filled in with polymer races and you end
up with a full length molecule which can
then be amplified and cloned into a
suitable vector transformed into e.coli
and colonies can be picked to verify the
correct sequence of a monoclonal
molecule that's basically how gene
synthesis works and the overall process
depending on the workflow that you use
may take about five days
synthesis has become true commodity over
the years and to date we have many many
customers that don't really bother
cloning anymore and amplifying a
sequence from some template in the
fridge using primers to modify
restriction sites and so on but they
just order this sequence that they have
in the computer anyway they are
synthetic genes are today used in all
kinds all areas of biotechnology like
basic research they used in functional
assays for antibody production for
protein production actually also for
optimization of proteins and enzymes if
you adapt synthetic genes to directed
evolution which is possible you can use
synthetic genes as positive controls for
DNA detection essays you can use them
for cell and optimization actually for
anything you can think of where you need
DNA
so in this picture this is kind of the
portfolio that we currently offer within
synthetic biology at thermo Fisher gene
art of course we help our customers to
design projects according to their
specific needs we do gene optimization
and gene synthesis which I just
explained a little bit and we can make
gene variants if you for example want to
do an alanine scan and require several
hundred or of different similar
sequences we can do this as well we can
make gene libraries for page display for
example creating huge diversity in these
synthetic genes sub cloning is actually
a big part of our portfolio because we
have many customers who say yes I want
the synthetic gene but please provide it
in this and that vector then plasmid
production up to milligram levels and
then also cell lines and proteins which
I'm going to focus on now
I want to explain a little bit what gene
optimization is and how it works so as I
mentioned before biotechnology is
possible or is actually easy because the
the language of all the organisms is
basically the same and it's easy to
transfer a gene from one organism to
another and have a good chance that it
actually works however here's a small
part of some codon usage tables of four
organisms a plant human yeast and e.coli
and if you look at the six synonymous
arginine codons and look at the columns
of humans and he coli you will notice
that humans with the blue shaded numbers
prefer some different codons than e coli
the blue shaded codons and vice-versa
the rare codons in E coli are the most
frequently used codons and Homo sapiens
and so on that means if you for example
take an insulin gene from a human and
plant it into bacteria it will work
however it will work with not the most
frequent codons and that may have an
impact on the expression levels of that
specific insulin protein
you
that's about codon usage codon usage is
not the only parameter in the dialect of
the different organisms I would say
there are other parameters that can be
adapted as well and that's for example
GC counter content
everybody knows that different organisms
have a different GC content and it's a
good idea to adapt the GC content to the
host in order to facilitate or to
guarantee genetic stability good
performance and also good expression
then for example cryptic splice sites
may be an issue if you go from if you
express in a human in mammalian cell it
may be a cDNA or gene from another
species then it may happen that there's
a cryptic splice site and the mRNA is
not processed correctly and you end up
with zero expression there's actually a
very famous example when they first try
to express jellyfish GFP in tobacco they
got zero expression and they found that
the jellyfish cDNA contains a cryptic
splice site which is recognized by the
plant and the DNA the RNA is not
processed correctly premature
polyadenylation signals may also be an
issue in 40m mrna design or iya design
direct repeats in the in the DNA may
lead to instability netic instability in
direct repeats may lead to RNA secondary
structure which also hamper translation
and then for example in plants their
so-called killer sequences that's a tea
rich sequence or sequence stretches that
have a impact on the mRNA half-life and
lead to a faster degradation of the mRNA
so all these parameters can be taken
into account when you optimize
gene in silico now optimization of gene
and silikal is actually not that trivial
and that is because the number of
sequences coding for one and the same
protein is astronomically high it's the
number of combinations of all the
synonymous codons so how did we solve
that that problem and I show you here
short animation of how our algorithm
basically works so you see that our
album algorithm for this short peptide
would come up with the most preferred
codon for almost all amino acids but
that 3:09 is coded by the second most
frequent codon for what reason in this
specific case I don't know maybe the
algorithm said okay I rather use ACA
instead of ACC because a cc would push
the GC content over a certain threshold
or splice site would be generated or
maybe a restriction site would be
generated which should be included and
so on so I mentioned that the number of
combinations of different codons is
astronomically and how does our
algorithm solve that it's a sliding
window approach so imagine that in the
first row you see a small sliding window
covering six different codons and for
these six codon positions it generates
all different or all possible
combinations and chooses the best one
fitting to all the parameters GC content
most frequent use codon no splice sites
and so on then the first codon is fixed
the sliding window moves one one amino
acid further and it does the same thing
again
then the first first codon is fixed and
so on so and that way it slides over the
complete window the complete open
reading frame that's our approach and it
leads to a sequence which uses the most
frequent codon as much as possible but
it also takes all the other parameters
into account
now about protein production next thing
many scientists when they think about
protein production think about a coli
because e.coli is fast it's easy
handling it's cheap well studied but
expression in e.coli has a number of
disadvantages it has no pros
translational modifications no membrane
environment for membrane proteins it
often leads to miss falling and
aggregation and inclusion bodies it has
some restrictions to large size or early
chimeric proteins and of course no
process inflation so also no
glycoproteins are possible Amalia of
course circumvent all these
disadvantages of e.coli that has it's
very own obstacles sometimes when alien
expression has some transcriptional
silencing the mRNA may be unstable in
the cell alternative splicing may happen
premature pollination or congenital
translation is inefficient and all these
things they can be overcome in to a good
design of the gene before you synthesize
it we have actually tested this in a
study a couple of years ago which we
have published and you will find the
reference and a few slides we have taken
50 genes 50 human genes and have
synthesized them as a wild-type version
and have optimized them and synthesized
them in an optimized version you may ask
ok why optimize human genes for human
expression because we then took these
into human cells and express them but of
course our genes in our body are not
optimized for highest yield but they are
optimized for highest performance in the
overall context of the cell so
expression maximum expressions of course
never a goal of almost never goal of the
evolution and the design of our genes so
here's some snapshots of the outcome all
the transactions and quantifications on
the Western blot were done in triplicate
and you see for a crept one a
transcription factor and the top row
that it's in notice blue on the Western
blog very nicely that the optimized
version had a higher expression than the
wild-type and in that case it's a 2.5 a
2.8 fold increase of expression and then
the same is true for the other ribosomal
protein for protein kinases for membrane
proteins for cytokines so on the top row
il-2 we actually did not detect any
expression when we transacted the
wild-type a cDNA but with the optimized
we got a faint band so in that case it's
from zero to something expression and
overall for the 50 genes we observed
that 996 percent of the cases for these
50 proteins we got an equal or a higher
protein expression actually in 86
percent the optimized version gave a
significantly higher expression than the
wild-type and ten percent it was equal
and only in two cases or four percent
the optimized gene expressed less than
the wild-type
so what that means is overall you get a
higher expression but also the
reliability that you get a detectable
expression at all is much much higher
overall we got of 24 25 fold increase up
to 25 fold increase in protein yields
and only two of those cases were
actually
did perform less than the wild-type
version
you
so all these tests were made in two nine
three cells and we wanted to see whether
it we get the similar results in Chinese
hamster cells and in SF nine insect
cells and basically you see that with
the green arrows the results were very
comparable so op gene optimization
worked equally well in 293 and in cho
cells and in one case in the insect
cells it was no in there hector and
three cells it was less and india even
in the SF nine cells the expression rate
was higher as compared to the wild type
versions
you
now how does what what's the mechanism
behind gene optimization I explained the
parameters codon frequency GC content
but what's the conceptual what's the
concept behind optimization and why does
it lead to a high expression we have
tested in this case for mid 1 alpha
several parameters in the transfect
itself so you see obviously it has an
effect on the overall expression level
of the protein in that case with the
optimized version we got a three-fold
better expression as compared to the
wild type if we looked at the de novo
synthesis rate so the nuclear run-on
rate of transcription we also find found
a 30% increase of that particular step
in in the overall expression or
translate transcription and translation
context also if we looked at the mRNA
stability we found a 14% increase of of
the stability of mRNA probably due to a
slightly higher GC content as compared
to the wild type
um
then on a northern blot we found that
the optimized mRNA did not perform any
better when it comes to nuclear export
so wild-type and optimized mRNA were
equally well exported from the nucleus
into the cytoplasm and the mRNA steady
state levels were 18% higher
that's probably an effect that comes
from both from the de novo synthesis
rate so the nuclear run-on of the mRNA
and the mRNA stability in combination
gave 80% higher mrna abundance inside
the cell and overall of course the
translational efficiency was 20% higher
so that means that the mRNA once it is
there the efficiency of turning this
into a protein on the ribosome was also
20% higher as compared to wild-type
maybe due to the lack of any or the
elimination of secondary structures in
the mRNA
hmm when we optimize genes for our
customers we often get the question yeah
okay I see that the expression rate can
be increased but will the final protein
be functional I tend to answer that this
is a general question in biotechnology
whenever you have a gene from one
organism to transfer it from one
organism into another then you are in a
I would say codon context that is not
natural in terms of it has adapted by
evolution so but in this case and so
that's it's the same thing whether it's
from another organism and coming into a
cell or whether it's synthetic coming
into a cell and it's not there's no
conceptual difference however of course
you can argue if protein is expressed
really high then maybe it lacks the time
for proper folding and may lead to a
larger proportion of non-functional
protein so I will show you here an
example of three proteins kindnesses in
that case which we expressed in also
again coming from wild-type DNA or from
optimized cDNA and for junk I and they
all expressed better were from the
optimized genes and for Jan kinase one
we did prosper relation si and in a
nutshell what we found is that the
protein coming from the wild-type gene
of course was able to give a positive
kinase signal but this Jean kinase
coming from an optimized gene ahead the
very same
which you see on the very right side
with a phosphate specific antibody so
there was no difference in that case we
could show that both proteins or the
same protein coming from both genes had
very comparable function another
interesting thing that you can do with
optimized genes now the optimized gene
has a different sequence than the
wild-type gene that means that the
optimized genes will react differently
to an SI RNA than the wild-type gene so
if you design si RNA against the
wild-type gene it's unlikely that or you
can design the optimized gene in a way
that D si RNA will not silence the
optimized gene and we did this with
cyclin dependent kinase 2 which is a
cell cycle regulator and you see on the
so and the facts plot on the top left
this is the untracked itself as usual
most cells are in the g0 g1 phase and
only few cells are in the g2 2 phase if
we transfect a nice i RNA against the
wild-type cdc2
then more cells are arrested in t2 now
if we transfect this SI RNA together
with an optimized gene for cdc2 then
cdc2
can be expressed again and this si R&A
cannot silence the optimized version and
on the bottom left you see that again
the fraction of cells in arrested in g2
decrease
so that's a very interesting function to
or feature of optimized jeans to to
validate si RNA functionality so the
summary of the study is that we could
show with 50 genes that gene synthesis
and gene optimization really increases
the overall expression and the success
rate of successful protein expression it
improves general yields and it does not
alter the solubility or the activity of
encoded protein and allows to confirm si
RNA phenotypes
now there are of course other companies
out there competitors who also offer
gene synthesis and gene optimization and
we have taken a closer look about
different optimization strategies so in
silico optimization strategies some of
them are very different from ours and
some of them are similar to ours I would
say we have synthesized such genes from
different competitors designed from
different competitors and tested them in
a mammalian expression analysis here and
so in a nutshell what you see here is
that again the gene art optimized genes
at a leaf about 3 fold higher expression
than the wild-type gene but then there's
also expression levels from genes
optimized from competitors and they are
all or expressed less than than the gene
are not just the gene art-design gene
but even less than the wild-type gene
which of course is not very favorable
because you typically want to increase
and not decrease your expression
so on this slide what I just want to
focus you on is that the protein service
that we offer is not the only service
that we have in our portfolio around
gene synthesis there's many other
products which most of you are likely to
be familiar but here and this particular
talk should be focused on the proteins
and expression in heck intro ended
insect self
poor Dean's are for the expression we of
course rely on the excellent reagents
that thermo Fisher allows us to use and
that is of course free style and since a
year for Joe or since three years four
to nine three cells the XP system and
what does the service look like there's
different kinds of requests from
customers and we have shaped our
services around these different needs
from customers so if you would need a
protein to be synthesized we need from
you and amino acid sequence
electronically or an accession number
and that's basically it but then you
also need to specify on your
expectations so the yield that you need
this can be specified culture volume you
may say okay please deliver whatever you
get from one liter culture and you can
of course also specify which cells you
prefer whether it's two nine three or
cho cells or insect cells and in that
case you would of course get the
synthesized gene in an expression
plasmid you would get the purified
protein from that specified culture
volume or you may also get the rare raw
culture supernatant or the cell pellet
in if you need a specified protein
amount then that's also possible also
with the same cells and with the same
deliverables but we need to do a gene to
protein pilot first so what we would do
then is we make a small culture volume
transfect that expression construct do
the expression also do a time course
about the harvest day do purification
and then we know what yield we got from
that particular culture volume and can
then upscale accordingly to meet the
specified protein amount that you
requested
you
so next I want to talk a little bit
about some customer success stories some
show you some examples on how gene
optimization and gene synthesis and in
conjunction with the XP systems works or
gives a better performance for our
customers this first example is still
without the XP system in that case we
made all nine combinations of three
different light chains with three
different heavy chains for a customer
and the customer already gave us some on
the top left table you see a gave us
some expression yields that he was able
to achieve and on the right hand table
you see what expression levels we
achieved after we optimized the genes
and expressed that and down there you
see the same results also in a bar so
the overall increase was about 20 to 50%
50 fold and in one case even 650 fold
increase
you
II
Joe was different iterations I would say
of combinations of gene vector and
production cell line so different aunt
if six different antibodies from a
customer and the white bars and the
graph represent the wild-type gene and
customer in-house production those
expression levels and then
dark blue bars are already optimized
gene but in a customer vector and with
the freestyle ternary self so already an
increase and the gray bars is optimized
gene man now in pcdna 3.3 vector and in
a freestyle system in some cases for
antibody 3 and 4 that gave a nice
increase and then the the right blue
bars are then everything optimized
optimized gene PCD and a 3.3 and XP 2 9
3 which in almost all cases gave much
higher yield of protein expression for
the sake of time I will touch this only
very loosely because I have some other
so here's some antibody expression
results comparison of XP 2 9 3 versus XP
Cho and basically shows that both
expression system work remarkably good
and give well folded antibody you see
that in the chromatogram HPLC plot down
there and heavy and light chain are well
folded and into a full functional
antibody
this is what doctor
of a protein looks like it's a little
bit hard to read I think on a small
screen however what I want to say here
is that you get a for our customers get
full documentation about all the aspects
that were used from gene synthesis to
protein production and purification so
starting from the sequence of course is
documented and then which vector is used
with which expression cells the culture
volume how it has been purified if ended
what the endotoxin levels are of the
protein the concentration how it looks
on a Kumasi gel what the HPLC
purification looked like which fractions
have been pooled for the protein and
with a final chromatogram of the pure
then purified protein
this documentation is highly
customizable and is usually discussed in
advance with a customer and each and
every project
here I can show you how easy it is to
order proteins mm synthetic proteins so
on the thermal website actually it's
easiest to just google gene synthesis
thermo Fisher you find a gene art gene
synthesis tab and if you click on that
there's a link to gene arts cell lines
and proteins and on the website that you
reach then there's a small download
button that allows you to download a
request form which you can then email to
the given address that's basically it
and then that form you can enter of
course the sequence or the accession
number and what purification method you
need what yield you need and so on so
already going through the overview what
I hope I was able to show you is that
with our gene optimization we can
increase significantly the protein yield
in the mammalian system of course also
in other systems but here we're focusing
on mammalian expression there's full
design flexibility if you want to use
gene further and require specific
restriction sites or Gibson cloning site
yeah
designed for Gibson cloning then this
can all be included in the design we of
course used in vitro gen vectors huge
that's compatible with the XP system we
have high quality plasmid preparation in
order to basically to minimize endotoxin
evel's in the protein and the whole
process is done in-house and that of
course allows for best turnaround time
from the electronic sequence to the
purified protein
and yeah I don't want to read that out
loud we express in to line three cells
in XP and Freesat style system and also
in cho cells and in back-to-back sf9 SF
21 and high five systems we of course
purify the proteins on F plc an HPLC
on different columns which are of course
project specific and upon customer needs
we analyze the proteins that we
synthesized with Center page 280 nano
meter a quantification also with a blitz
if it is a an antibody with HPLC and we
are just setting up a mass spec then so
that will be part of on an analysis QC
as well
so the gene to protein I said in record
time the overall gene to protein service
typically takes 30 business days but can
be faster in times that really depends
on specific project like the size of the
gene and the required yields of the
protein and so on the performance is
extremely reliable our gene synthesis
reliability is about 100 percent and
then it comes to proteins there are the
results a little bit more varying but we
usually almost always get measurable
expression but of course that's very
much protein dependent expression
protein expression is extremely scalable
and very flexible so we produce from 100
milliliter cell culture volumes up to 25
liter wave back volumes
and the whole system is very secure
of course the whole e-commerce system is
iso certified and of course our staff is
trained also accordingly and with that I
hope that I have given you some overview
of our gene to protein services at
thermo Fisher gene art and I'm happy to
take some of your questions if you may
absolutely thank you dr. list thank you
dr. list of an informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started our first question
is do you recommend incorporating signal
sequences in the construct to express
membrane proteins if it's a membrane
protein then of course it already has a
signal sequence if it's a mammalian
membrane protein that is we do an
analysis of the sequences prior to the
design if we detect a single sequence
then we know it's secreted or ends up in
the membrane if it does not have one
then it's in this we discuss with a
customer whether you want it to have it
secrete it then we can add an artificial
signal sequence in order to secrete it
or if it comes from another organism and
should end up in the membrane to end up
in the membrane okay thank you what is
the major factor at the level of
transcription for a non expresser or
poorly expressed protein
can you repeat that question please yes
what is the major factor at the level of
transcription for a non Express ER or
poorly expressed protein hmm I mean
that's a hypothesis that it's if it's
poorly expressed that it is due to low
transcription I would say my best answer
is of course it's a matter of a good
promoter in order to have a high a good
transcription second is that the 5 prime
5 prime end of the mRNA should be
somehow relaxed maybe a little bit baby
a little bit a team or a tea rich in
order to facilitate transcription but
then I think it's it has but what has
more impact on the level of expression
in terms of mr or RNA is not so much the
transcriptional activity but more the
stability of PM RNA in the nucleus so if
you think about cytokines for example of
course they are expressed extremely well
upon inflammatory signal for example in
our cells but they should be expressed
only for a short time and therefore they
have a very short half-life the mRNA
have a very short half-life so that this
protein concentration diminishes quickly
enough and the cytokines make this
possible due to specific a T rich
regions in the mRNA
thank you apart from codon optimization
does Kozak sequence have any major
effect we typically include a cosmic
sequence I personally and and that's
that's a little better religious
question I personally don't believe more
I haven't seen a much much convincing
data that the Kazakh sequence really
helps we include it because still it
appears quite a bit in the literature
that its state-of-the-art to include a
cosmic sequence and for us it's easy
yeah it's a few nucleotides more and
doesn't add to the cost and it doesn't
harm at least so we typically add a
Kazakh sequence but we haven't seen
convincing evidence that it actually
helps the next attendee says thank you
and asks is the optimization free or
connected with an order
again can you repeat that please
yes is the optimization free or
connected with an order free
great simple as that how long did it
take to receive a protein and what is
your turnaround time yeah that depends a
little bit on the overall scope of the
order so in the for the most
comprehensive service you send us a
[Music]
sequence electronically we synthesize
the gene do a larger scale a plasmid
preparation transfect a liter of cells
and incubated cells for six seven days
then harvest purify polish the protein
to the fill and finish and the
quantification that takes about 30
business days it can be faster if the
scale is lower or sometimes customers
say I have the expression plasmid
already I'm going to send you that so we
can skip the gene design and the
synthesis gene synthesis part but can
start right away with plasmid
preparation and with transfection then
it's shorter but I think around about 30
business day is a very good number to
start with this next one is a two-parter
I'll read both parts in case it's
helpful and then let me know if you need
me to repeat the second part do you also
code on optimize the reader sequence and
is it sometimes better if the
translation in the leader holds for
allowing a better folding yes we do
optimize the leader sequence and we have
no observations that it up to
optimization hampers in any way folding
or functionality of the protein I would
say that 80% of the proteins that we're
making are actually antibodies and of
course here the demand is that the
expression rates are as high as possible
in the yields
and so we use the yeah we have never
seen that antibody lacks folding or
proper phenotype upon optimization of
the leader peptide okay thank you the
next one is when should somebody prefer
insect cell expression over mammalian
cell expression that's a good question I
think I can't give you good answer to
that because I personally haven't worked
with insect cells before from what I
know though is that some proteins
Express extremely well in insect cells
and of course the nice thing is that if
you choose the insect expression system
then the first thing that you do is you
generate virus baculovirus and with that
you infect the cells so that is kind of
a Perpetua stiff source of of
reinfection of new cells so it's once
you have the virus it's very easy and
very fast to make new protein batches
this I see is one of the advantages and
then from what I've heard is that some
proteins just Express extremely well and
insect cells do you incorporate five
prime UTR for protein production
purposes apart from the Kozak sequence
usually not there are within the five
prime UTR are within the vector and the
PC three-point-three that preferred for
the XP system already contains all these
parts which is essentially a really
strong promoter and other than that
nothing else is necessary
which purification which purification
methods do you offer including epitope
tags hmm so routinely as I said we 80%
of the proteins that we're doing are
antibodies of course these we typically
purify with the FC with their sea part
with protein a and gel filtration for
polishing but we also use other tags
like histep tag strep tag flag tag or
other customer specified tags we can
also leave the tag up on tags upon
expression here we usually use teff but
can also use other proteases for
cleavage of the tags
do you offer membrane protein
purification no membrane provocation is
a very specific I would say art already
and it can become very tedious and very
protein specific we do offer membrane
protein expression but in these cases we
typically deliver only the cell pellet
but of course we verify the expression
with the Western blot but then leave it
up to the customer to use the cell
pellet for further use of the membrane
protein
what is part of your QC or what is
included in the documentation hmm
I shown it documentation before so yes
for the protein it's a standard Kumasi
gel of denatured and native protein then
the concentration as measured by OD 280
Western blot then for antibodies we
usually do a protein a based blitz titer
determination and then optional are
other QC methods like HPLC or an endo
tox test is also optional or mass spec
things like that how much protein will I
get if I order your service it's highly
dependent on the protein itself of
course so if you order the volume option
which is please transfect a liter of
culture and get me whatever you can
express from that then it's open what
the expression levels will be so from
antibodies I can tell you that typically
from a liter of transfected cells we
achieve 100 to 300 milligram of antibody
but there's already also depends on the
antibody itself but if you say no I want
100 milligram of this and that protein
then we have to do a pilot first and
then second scale up on volume according
to the results of that pilot we have
time for one more question
I am surprised to see your results that
code on optimization from different
vendors work very differently major
differences
that's not really a question yeah but I
I hear I can I can understand that
surprise and I would this is this is
kind of a showcase but we have done
these studies for other proteins as well
and we see maybe not that extreme but we
see very similar results so you can make
that experiment on your own you can go
to different vendors and do the
optimization on their website and see
the results you can hit the optimize
button several times and from some
vendors with their algorithm you will
see that every time the sequence will be
different when you optimize it so it's a
stochastic algorithm that's one thing
that would make me suspicious what you
can also do you can take a sample
sequence optimize it at different
vendors and then look at the GC content
and you will see differences in the GC
content and then if you look at what is
the optimal GC content for mammalian
expression just by looking at the
sequence or the GC content you will
observe that some of them may have a
higher likelihood to express better than
others so this is an experiment I would
suggest you to do if you're interested
to dig into this to get more confidence
and in this but I really can assure you
that the results that I have shown you
may be extreme art but are kind of
representative from what we observed
with many different other proteins as
well well I would like to once again
thank dr. list for his presentation I
would also like to thank Cyril Thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019
please share with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event also
stay tuned for our next presentation
cryo-electron microscopy
revolutionising the world of structural
biology and healthcare it is presented
by mark MH storms a product marketing
manager in the life sciences business
unit of the materials and structural
analysis and analytical instruments
group at Thermo Fisher Scientific you
won't want to miss it that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye
thank you goodbye everybody